In this course,
you'll be using Google Chrome and
Chrome's developer tools,
which we call Devtools for short.
If you haven't used
Chrome Devtools before,
check out the link in the instructor
notes for some information and
instructions for getting started.
You can use Devtools to quickly get
an idea of how your site performs on
a rage of different devices.
However, emulators and simulators can
never really replace the experience of
using a real phone or tablet.
To test your work on a phone or
tablet, you'll need to make sure
you're set up to use remote debugging.
For the remainder of this lesson,
you will be getting some instructions
from Peter Lovers on how to get started
with mobile DevTools and
debugging on your mobile devices.
If you're already familiar
with mobile debugging,
feel free to skip ahead to
the video called Lesson One Wrapup.